Speaker 1: Let's talk next. Where do we want
to go next? There's a lot of folks here.
What about? Let's go to is it Tyler from
St? Where is it, St? St. Louis? Is it?
Taylor Taylor.
Speaker 2: Yes, it is.
It is from St. Louis, I bungled up my name, but
I wanted to ask about what what is what is up
with the advertisements on your channel with
always involving crypto? Like, what do you mean?
Speaker 1: Like, most of our advertisers
have nothing to do with crypto.
Speaker 2: You always you always do
these single video advertisements and they're
always sketchy crypto currency sort of things.
Speaker 1: I think we did one in
the last few weeks. Can you give
me an example of it being sketchy crypto?
Speaker 2: One of them was one of them was in
nifty thing, which was the most recent one
and the other and the other. I don't exactly
remember the name is a name of, but it ended
up and ended up failing because of numerous
FEC warnings against it.
Speaker 1: OK, please don't use push to talk.
We're hearing the Discord Billings come through
in terms of the NFT. So are you talking about
a cryptocurrency or now you're saying NFT? These
are two different things. Which one did you mean?
Speaker 2: I was
meaning the I was meaning all of them.
Speaker 1: OK, but so but is this call
about the recent NFT one or a cryptocurrency
because these are I can I can't address them
generally if there's a specific buy.
Speaker 2: I guess we can. I guess.
I guess you could address the recent NFT
advertisement because a lot of people
do not approve of you advertising these things.
Speaker 1: Oh, OK. Yeah. I mean, listen,
we have advertisers. We make clear when things are
sponsored or it's an advertiser. I can't think of
any advertiser that I've not had people complain
about when we have, you know, a serial company.
People write in saying the cereal is expensive
and not very good, and we really shouldn't be
associated with them when we have a knife company,
people say the type of steel the knives are made
of is no good when we know we never have
the perfect advertiser. And so what we're
trying to do is we run an ad program. We have
advertisers. We mark things as advertisements.
We allow people to make decisions
about any advertiser that they want
and note there is no way everybody will be
happy with every advertiser, that's for sure.
Speaker 2: OK.
Speaker 1:
All right, and then the individual hung
up, OK. All right, let's go to the next.
I figured there would be some
kind of dialog, but I guess not.